Re-shooting video ten, create and evaluate an estimator.
Let's summarize where we are.
So recall we started with the initial general question,
can we predict the next time a person will tweet?
So we started with a general question,
can we predict the next time a person will tweet.
We decided to use the number of seconds since last tweet,
in order to quantify the problem.
We decided that we wanted to estimate the number of seconds since last tweet,
using the regression estimator.
And we modeled that regression estimator using an exponential fit,
which gave us an initial data parameter of 1451.5 seconds.
We then used half things inequality to put a confidence band around that.
Now, let's see how this guess turns out.
So, for each value in our time until next list,
we're going to subtract from it, our guess of 1451 and a half seconds.
Then we'll just collect those values, in this list (exp_diffs).
And, just to pick up from where we were before,
here's a histogram of those sign differences.
So, the first thing you might notice,
which is very interesting, is that most of this graph occurs before 0.
The meaning of this is that most of the time our guess is
over estimating the actual intertweet time, so
to make this quantitative let's use the describe method.
As you can see here, over 50% of the time it overestimates the time until
next tweet, by at least 18 and a half minutes.
Now in the next video we'll continue to investigate the results of our model,
but before we do that it's time for a quiz.